so hello everybody I am here with Owen
Cyclops Owen Cyclops is an artist who
does illustrations that use a lot of
symbolism a lot of Christian symbolism a
lot of weird symbolism and I encountered
him on Twitter and I was so impressed by
his work that I decided to Commission
him an image based on the watch the
fools theme in my videos the notion that
the fool is also there to flip things
when things are chaotic to bring the
King back but they have to bring order
back when the world is upside down and
so we just finished this image last week
I put it on some merch and I'm putting
it out there as this video is playing
and so I'm really excited to talk to
Owen to figure out about his own journey
through art through symbolism also
through religious ideas and and get a
sense how we connect
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world and so Owen maybe you can
give us a bit of a sense of your journey
about your work and kind of where you
get your inspiration and where you feel
like you're going right now
yeah man yeah I'm really glad to be here
well basically in a nutshell I guess you
could say my kind of path my artistic
path spiritual also because those are
kind of the same thing for me actually
would be that I was pretty much the I've
always been into religion mysticism and
things like that but I would describe
myself previously as kind of like the
caricature of white guy in his 20s
really into like psychedelics and
vaguely Eastern stuff and maybe seeing
myself on kind of like a Foshan monocore
like Western occult path so I really
lived in that world for a really long
time I was really into Buddhism Western
occult and was kind of just floating for
a really really long time
and eventually I became Christian
probably like two two-and-a-half years
ago now and it's interesting it's kind
of one of those things where like in in
Buddhism actually there's a debate
whether you get enlightened all at once
or whether it's gradual so the joke is
kind of that it's gradual until it's all
at once and it's kind of how I feel
looking back at my work in my path and
stuff it's like it did happen kind of
all at once one day but there also was a
slow build-up where I was figuring
things out so yeah basically now I view
myself as I mean I I never really used
this terms it sounds kind of pretentious
I guess but kind of like a reformed
occultist
in her way I really do view myself as
someone that was on like a particular
path and then I got off of it and now
I'm in Christendom and that's a huge
part of my work is exploring that and
bringing you know what I know and what I
did into the light of that and also
taking the light of that worldview and
bringing it back to all the other things
that I'm interested I guess the other
piece of it not to go on too much with
myself would be that part of that whole
world is being into just kind of weird
things in general whether it's like
paranormal stuff maybe even touching on
like construe
see world or just kind of the whole
strange set of odd things that happen in
life so yeah now I am kind of going back
and bringing the worldview I have now
into that and things kind of make a lot
more sense and then my art has always
been married to that whole process yeah
well it's interesting when you talk
about the idea being a reformed
occultist or something like that I I
really have a theory about about that I
know a lot of people that kind of came
to Christianity and more traditional
Christianity even let's say Eastern
Orthodoxy or more traditional
Catholicism who actually come out of an
occult past you could say and my my
theory about that is that the
Christianity became so milquetoast you
know in the the later centuries let's
say towards around 17th 18th century you
became very materialistic and
Protestantism but also Counter
Reformation was part of that that the
the mystical aspect was almost forgotten
it's as if it kind of faded away and or
was left there that no one knew what to
do with it and so it was taken up by all
these these stranger parts and so the
what I felt is that people who are
looking at the occult usually their
desire is not is not bad they want to
find something deeper they want to get a
deeper connection they want to
understand you know how these patterns
manifest themselves you know they can
see that that's what some of these
occult writers are talking about but
sadly they end up with a kind of
piecemeal solution you know the
occultism is very fragmentary and it's
very it lacks the full metaphysical
structure that that traditional
christianity offers and so i've noticed
that a lot of those people when they
come back then they see something like
Eastern Orthodoxy they encounter you
know the writing of the Church Fathers
and how powerful it is and how you know
the let's say the little things they got
from magic in terms of understanding how
ritualized reality is they notice that
communion that you know the liturgical
year the liturgical structure is you
know it's whatever you learned about
magic it's that times a thousand you
know it's it's actually world building
it actually it actually holds reality
together and so it's just interesting to
see that you have your kind
on that a similar peso are you are you
part of a group like are you in a
particular church I am NOT actually it's
not really it's actually not by design
at all really I guess you could say is
that when I first kind of got on board I
decided that I should take some time and
just kind of get my own life together
and get my head straight and what I told
myself was I was gonna focus kind of on
my relationship with like God more than
trying to pick like a particular group
to be with I think also in the very
beginning you know like I wouldn't say
like I you hit rock bottom but like you
hit the wall and you're like okay this
is not the road to go down
maybe the theological my new show
doesn't matter like as much at that
point but after a year maybe a little
bit more than that I started to feel
like I kind of had to figure it out a
little bit so I've been doing my own
like theological investigations and
stuff like that I guess right now where
I'm at is I'm more sympathetic to
apostolic secession style Christianity
that being like Catholicism and
orthodoxy but I guess I'm kind of at
this point where I can see where
everyone's coming from and I do it goes
back and forth between being like
something that's on the front burner for
me where I'm like all right I really
gotta like figure this out but sometimes
I feel like I'd like you don't know if
you were born into orthodoxy or not but
I feel like for me oh cool so yeah for
me it goes back and forth between being
like something that is genuinely coming
from my like need for spiritual refuge
but then also sometimes you know we were
just talking about Twitter a minute ago
it does become kind of like an ego
aggrandizing exercise and when I get to
that point I kind of put it on the back
burner again when I'm like oh it's my
job like I'm gonna come in and decide
this like theological debate from
centuries ago like me I'm so important
so I go back and forth I'm figuring out
slowly you could say yeah well I think
there isn't there's a great value in
kind of engaging I talk about this a lot
in my on my channel it's hard to do
because the world is so spectator like
our whole world is very spectator like
but there is a great value in
participative patterns right where you
actually engage inside the pattern that
so going to a church part
debating in the liturgy submitting to a
priest like submitting to a spiritual
father
all of these these gestures make you
participate in these these symbolic
patterns that we notice in the world you
know so I mean I would say I mean you'll
figure it out on your own at some point
you'll slowly kind of find your way
hopefully into some community and so
will trust God to kind of bring you
towards the bring you towards whatever
whatever ends up being the best for you
in that moment yeah yeah I think it's
happening slowly yeah I'm kind of in
this weird Venn diagram overlap where
like I don't belong to a group but I'm
also not one of those people who's like
yeah it doesn't matter it's all kind of
the same anyway so right yeah I don't
need to like clarify a little bit yeah
so so the thing that really kind of
attracted me to your art was of course
it's very symbolic in the sense that
it's very you use a lot of imagery that
that is structured in a way that's very
hieratic you know that it's very it's
like almost like logo like it's not it
doesn't take realism as its basis it
doesn't take the the desire to show you
know like the shadow of something the
shadow of something on something else or
the color but it's really typifies and
so there's a kind of strange a very
interesting mix of graphic art in your
work iconography Christian iconography
and almost a even a graffiti aesthetic
you could say bringing it also into a
knowledge of Western symbolism and of
course also Western esoteric symbolism
so that's kind of one of the questions
that I had for you and it's funny
because someone came at me on Twitter
because of it because I was kind of I
was promoting your work on Twitter and
someone came at me and said oh he's
using and he's using occult symbolism
using esoteric symbolism and I think
that I come at it also from a point of
view the point of view that I mentioned
before which is that I see a lot of the
esoteric Christianity that appeared in
the West as a desire to explore the
deeper aspects of Christianity now they
did it in a way that sometimes went
totally off the rail that sometimes is
unacceptable yes we can all acknowledge
that
for example like it you use some
Rosicrucian symbolism one of your images
and you had a rose in the center of the
cross and someone was saying oh that's
Rosie crucian but okay so it's Rosie
crucian but are you looking at the
symbol what's wrong with the idea that
there's a rose at the center of the
Cross it's actually a very powerful
image of what the cross is what creation
is what is at the center of the cross
all of these things are being brought
together in a very powerful way so now
whether or not Rosicrucians exaggerated
or went off the rails or because of
their secret society status they were
involved in some kind of weird political
movement that's beyond well it's not
totally beyond the point but is it
possible for us to take these images
back right to bring them back and to
show their potential to participate in
the Christian narrative so I know if
it's something you thought about if
you're going about it more intuitively
oh yeah dude yeah I think about that all
the time for sure that's a big it's a
big part of my my art situation I guess
you could say yeah well for me it's
always like there's a really I guess you
could say a fine line where on the one
hand I think of it as like I never
really want to like concede territory to
some let's say ideologies or worldviews
that I'm not really about like that's a
perfect example like rose on the cross
together like it is kind of classical
like Christian medieval symbolism but
certain groups have like used it so
sometimes I'm sitting at my desk and I'm
like yeah well I'm not going to give up
this territory like I'm not never gonna
use this because of this like group or
whatever I had but then on the on the
flip side of that like I do have kind of
like a responsibility to not frankly
make certain things look like really
sexy and cool honestly I feel like a lot
of the kind of like shadowy amorphous
ideology stuff just gets by on it's like
frankly like sex appealing because it
looks really cool it's a lot a lot of it
is like primarily aesthetic actually so
yeah it's always a balance like a really
good example of that is like astrology
stuff I used to use like astrological
glyphs and things like that in my work
and it was never even really about
astrology it was more just about like
what it represented in terms of like the
zodiac is like a cohesive symbol set but
eventually I stopped because I didn't
want to maybe you know like I'm saying
give people kind of
idea or maybe someone would see it and
be like oh yeah like that is really cool
I should get this book on astrology and
then you know I've accidentally like
promoted that so I go back and forth
there's a few good examples for me one
of the examples I always use is like a
pentagram like you can go back and make
like an academic case like oh well in
medieval art like the pentagram
represented you know the five wounds of
Christ but at the same time I mean I
think the ship is kind of sailed on that
I'm not going to be like putting
pentagrams in my art you know so so
there's like oh there's like a fine line
you could say gonta yeah well there is
that I've been showing I've been
actually I've had this argument about
pentagrams with a few people where I
tried to show that there is a pentagram
structure in several Christian images
that the most obvious one is the image
of Christ on the throne with the four
cherubs around him
you have Christ's head in the at the top
and you have these four points you know
the four points of the four directions
kind of going away from him so he
appears it's actually exactly a
pentagram symbolism because he is the
top point as the head of these four
manifestations of himself and so it's
like I like you said I would never put a
straight-up pentagram in the in my
images of course but I say of course but
I wouldn't because of the same reason
you said but at the same time when
someone tells me that that a pentagram
is in itself evil or that in his it has
in itself some kind of evil meaning that
is included in the geometric shape
itself I I can't I can't handle that
like I just can't accept it I just have
to I end up calling it out every time
and say no a pentagram is a is a very
powerful shape it's very it has a lot of
meaning in it and it's it's there's
nothing illegitimate about it now we
obviously don't want to be a stumbling
stone for people as well but we have to
understand what it is if understanding
what a pentagram is it's very useful
because you can understand what it means
to have something above four corners
like to have something that is a top
four manifestations right so the four
Gospels or the four directions or
something like that so it can be useful
but I understand but I see that like for
example I noticed that you use the
all-seeing eye like you use the eye
the divine I which the same with the
roads in the cross is such a it's an
image which precedes any form of
Illuminati existence like it's a head
you see the medieval churches I had a
crazy example recently there's a church
nearby in this small city of in Quebec
and in one of the arches of the the roof
of the church there was a the ceiling of
the church there was an all-seeing eye
and we were doing a tour of the church
and a guy looked at it is and said to
his friend he said oh that means that
this is an Illuminati Church I was like
what you're completely insane there's
there's all-seeing eyes in churches all
over the all over the world from the
Middle Ages until the modern world so
it's not him doesn't mean that
Freemasons were involved in building
that church yeah the church there was
probably the least Illuminati place in
the city probably right I mean it's like
I don't think there were a lot of
Illuminati in in French Canadian peasant
culture like I'm not I'm sure there
wasn't a lot of that going on yeah yeah
I always think of this story there's I
obviously wish I could find out I
remember reading it somewhere but it was
something like these like townspeople
were talking about how the full moon is
like the time when like The Devil's
active and how the full moon is like
this evil symbol and I think it was a
saint or someone so I'm like holy person
was like you know actually what the
devil does is he just he just chooses to
do things when the moon is full so that
you guys associate evil with the full
moon and then this really beautiful
thing God made become this like
perverted symbol of evil and I really
really like that like little like tail
and that's something else I think about
also like you know an owl is another
perfect example like yeah secret
societies using owls but like at the
same time I mean God made out Sam I like
never gonna put one in my art probably
not right well yeah no you're right
exactly exactly the same but I think we
can also do a service to the world by re
explaining this symbolism in a way that
is more powerful than giving them over
to the dark side like you said like we
just let the dark side have this
symbolism then we're actually making
ourselves weaker rather if we are able
to reclaim it in a way that's legitimate
it's not just you know not just random
but we can do it in a way that's
legitimate and can help people
understand the deeper me
then then I think we can do it like you
know when you see someone you see that
kind of weird conspiracy side that
sometime that goes off the rails
you know when they see two pillars and
an arch and they think as soon as they
see two pillars in an arch all of a
sudden it's like this is this is like
Freemason or this is evil like dude you
can't you can't do that not two pillars
on an arch my goodness like you're
basically eliminating all of
architecture just with that strange that
strange enter that there's a keystone
like if they see a keystone they think
oh that's freemason like the Keystone is
not three Mason there's actually when
you see that that um the quote of Christ
when he talks about how the stone that
was rejected by the Builders became the
top of the angle it's like that's he's
it seems like it's referring to
something like a keystone or a capstone
rather than just the corner of an angle
because it's misshaped and right it's it
doesn't have the same shape as the
others and so it ends up being the final
stone which holds everything together so
Christ is actually using architectural
symbolism to talk about himself so if
you're gonna give that to your enemies
that you see as your enemies you're
gonna give that to them then you're
missing out on something totally yeah
yeah I couldn't agree more honestly and
so what is your because I've so I'm
looking at a bunch of images of you that
you're doing and you really seem to be
exploring more and more kind of
Christian symbolism and you're you're
using so you even made an icon of st.
Herman like a saint Herman of Alaska
tell me a little bit a bit about what
attracts you to st. Herman oh that's a
cool one well yeah just just off the bat
I mean some people listen this probably
don't know me I'm not famous
yeah just kidding but yeah all my work
is Christian for sure like even if I'm
just drawing like a flower or something
like that like I'm doing it like being
like a Christian context so it's
throwing that out there
um yeah well I made this image of st.
Herman because for a few reasons I guess
working backwards I'm really into
Seraphim Rose who's a really big like
influence on me partially because the
case people aren't familiar with his
work
the main in Rose for me was he has a
book called orthodoxy and the religion
of the future and even before I ever
would have thought about Christianity at
all someone told me this theory that
UFOs were related to demonology and that
like UFOs were a extension of you know
the demon illogical phenomenon from the
past and that just totally blew my mind
I was really kind of into the paranormal
at the time and I was like why never
would have thought of that
that came from Seraphim row so I read
the book and he's a really cool guy even
outside of that I don't want to
pigeonhole him is like the UFO demons
guy and he's associated with st.
Herman's monastery in Alaska so I
started looking into it and I just
thought he was a really cool figure and
I really liked the idea I mean I'm
American also in case people don't know
I just really liked the idea of
Christianity coming to America in the
most general sense whether it was
orthodoxy or Catholicism or anything
really and so he was a really
interesting figure in that context I'm
pretty sure he's this patron
I wouldn't say patron saint but he's
like called the wonder-worker of the
Americas or something in the church and
yeah he's a really cool guy I really
liked his life story which I kind of
Illustrated like in this image here and
yeah I just felt kind of a kinship with
him I guess you could say not that I'm
like similar to him but I kind of felt
an affinity for him that mean reward
yeah and the image that really I guess
this is related to what you're talking
about so I'll bring it up because the
image that that someone posted and then
I saw that really kind of struck me and
then got me connected to you is the
image of the mother of God cutting off
the cutting off the aliens head yes
yeah if I like a if I'd like a greatest
hits album that would definitely the
crowds would definitely put that on
there for sure I love it and I love the
fact that you see also you see like the
sea serpent
there are many images in that there are
many things in there where you see the
sea serpent getting his head cut in the
in the waters totally yeah this image is
actually a really good encapsulation of
like what I'm about just in general
honestly when I drew it just so also I
feel like I should just like qualify a
little bit like I really do take the
creating imagery that would be perceived
as religious or spiritual thing like
really seriously so like when I drew
this I wasn't thinking like oh this is a
picture of Virgin Mary I just kind of
drew it as like a somewhat generic like
holy woman so just so people know I'm
not over here like doodling like you
know and kind of taking it very
flippantly I guess you could say like
rendering like holy figures and stuff
you can see actually the st. Herman of
Alaska a mage is like totally different
than this one because he's like you know
a historical person this is just like a
generic figure so to clarify well I
wouldn't say I would like for sure I
wouldn't say it's an icon especially in
my Orthodox context like I don't think
this as an icon of the Virgin Mary but
it's obviously a figure which you call
some because you put a crown on top of
her head and you start up in the heavens
it's the illusions are very strong yeah
definitely yeah yeah but yeah this image
would be like a really perfect
encapsulation of my vibe honestly you
have this like holy woman like beheading
this alien over on the left was like the
angel coming down with like Noah's Ark I
was thinking about the Nephilim and
stuff like that that this guy getting
abducted in the bottom right I guess
yeah you could say that part of a part
of what I'm about is really like
integrating all of these things into a
view of the world that is theological I
guess you could say you know I was into
conspiracies for a long time nothing
nothing too crazy just saying maybe like
you know Bigfoot UFO nothing too crazy
there either and you know little things
like that and then I feel like when I
started getting a more theological
understanding of the universe even just
little things like you know why is evil
happen and why are things the way they
are it all becomes integrated in this
way so yeah pairing the theological
imagery with more unexpected things I
guess you could say is that probably big
part of what I'm about so the one weird
thing about that image the one which I'm
wondering about and I'll be honest is
just the image of the ladder with the
devil like atop the ladder yeah totally
yeah so over on the left there's the I
mean sorry on the right there's the guy
getting abducted from his house yeah
into like the night and then above that
he's getting led up this ladder and
there's like the devil there don't like
snatch him like at the top of the ladder
and there's also Saturn over there I
kind of like intentionally put that some
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah basically
what it's about is that I felt like
there there's this whole aspect to the
UFO and paranormal thing in general
where I really do feel like
is kind of designed to like ensnare
people and maybe lead them down these
like wrong roads there's a lot of
stories like that I mean I could go into
it but there's some many many stories
where someone would get like just
obsessed with like particular my anusha
of alien abduction experiences or their
soul starts seeing UFOs everywhere and
often it'll like totally destroy their
life on yeah yeah or things like you
know beings like that kind of leading
people into like a weird like sciency
Gnostic II cosmic II New Age religion
worldview so that's what I was thinking
over there it's like the guy gets
abducted and then he's led up this
ladder like to the devil and I guess it
looks a little weird cuz it's like in
the heavens but what I was thinking was
that you know in his mind he's like oh
I'm going up this ladder like I'm
ascending but then at the top it has a
surprise like has a bad surprise yeah
yeah I get I can I can kind of get it
just it's just because the ladder
especially in an iconography is
associated with like the Jacob's Ladder
so like the idea of going up the ladder
is usually associated with like going
coming near God but because it's almost
like you could call like the false
ascent or something like the ascent of
pride is what seems to be did to be to
be represented but I like the idea of
the of the of the person getting
abducted by aliens and then coming up
and realizing that it's it's the devil
yeah if I did if I did this again now it
would be cool to have like a longer like
more classically like angled ladder on
the left side that maybe did like go all
the way up to the heavens or something
so it'd be like more of an obvious like
comparison yeah well you could you could
like a good way could be to show the
flip because it's almost like a flip
you're at you
you get abducted into a spaceship so
you're physically going up like into the
spirits of the air or something and then
with what's actually happening is you're
actually going down the lap they're
going down the slide like you're
actually sliding down into the mouth of
hell do you look at the images of the
Last Judgement you'll get you might get
something some ideas about that you see
this either like a snake starting at the
foot of Christ going it's kind of
sliding you down into the mouth of Hell
or sometimes there's like a array of
fire which comes down from Christ's foot
and then that people kind of ride down
into the into the mouth of the of the of
the monster yeah I've seen those
it's something we kind of touched on
just like really quickly before but yeah
that's one thing that got me hooked into
I guess you could say sacred art in
general even when I was just kind of
starting my path was the ability to read
it and kind of get information out of it
was something that I thought was really
awesome I was making images and I was
painting but I'd kind of been more
schooled in like a you know 16 17 1800 s
like oil painting kind of aesthetic
situation so then when I started seeing
images and I was like wow this guy
basically wrote a book that I'm looking
at and I'm like I'm unpacking all of
this and it's telling me so much that
really like changed my artistic path
forever yeah that's I think I had the
same experience when I discovered
medieval art and especially um
especially that church decorations
because the church decorations they they
appear as this this like 3d system of
imagery that are relating to each other
that are kind of playing off each other
and so it ends up being really like a
system of meaning that is that is
manifesting itself to you you know that
you can it's a pattern really like it's
a pattern of it's an algebraic pattern
and so that's what I like about your
work is I did that's what it feels like
as well so you have this you put up all
these images next to each other and they
create these analogies that then bring
out the the meaning yeah totally sorry
do you want to say something no I'm just
gonna say yeah I spend a lot of time
like in different I think that's also
part of what I took away from being a
part of different kind of like
worldviews I guess you could say is
after you kind of do the whole survey
like every worldview theology religion
whatever it is has its sacred art that
kind of carries its worldview in it and
that was one of my other main
motivations for kind of doing what I do
is that I felt like for our modern
culture there's not really that there's
not really like oh here's a clear thing
that embodies like our kind of like
spiritual experience at this moment
that's how I felt at the time anyway so
yeah that was something else I wanted to
help help work on
and so who like who what kind of people
do you feel are the ones who are
responding to your work right now like
what's your quits your public like
that's interesting man I feel like I'm
in the overlap of a lot of Venn diagram
yeah that's what I feel too that's why I
asked yeah it's pretty interesting it's
interesting too because you know I I
think it's people that I mean on the one
hand well I guess you could say the main
kind of core in my opinion because this
is kind of how I feel and where I come
in it from is that I feel like there's a
lot of people who have been like young
guys at least I don't know vicious guys
but in my mind I'm a guy
whatever uh-huh like young guys maybe
who for a while it's kind of like
eventually you wake up to like wow like
things in society are really on ideal
and there's all these like large forces
and like I'm actually really like maybe
angry or not happy with this and I
really don't like it and I feel like at
first you're on the surface level of
that like maybe there's some like
particular political issue you're
interested in and yeah it's probably
important but then you kind of like go
deeper and you untangle all these like
webs of these interconnected wires and I
feel like eventually it kind of leads
you to like a theological view of things
where you're like oh there is like good
and evil and it's more than just like
things generated in the human mind you
know so I feel like I get a lot of
people like that who are like yeah I
have some kind of inkling that there's
some like theological nature to things
and I feel like I don't know if I
explained it well but yeah that's how
that's what I feel like it's kind of
like the core of people people who I
guess you could say are interested in
culture and society and how it's going
yeah and then that has dovetailed with a
theological understanding of the world
because that's me but then also on top
of that yeah there's other people who
are just into like weird like what I
call like third I weird stuff like could
be like Bigfoot or UFOs or anything a
lot of people who have maybe been on a
similar path to me who are like yeah I
used to really be really into like
psychedelics and stuff and now I'm like
kind of just floating and then also
people who maybe are Christian or have
been Christian but just enjoy seeing
like a different embodiment of it I
guess you could say I get a lot of
messages like that
you know I think that's the other thing
is like I'm very like realistic about
Who I am and what I do like you know you
mentioned before like yeah I would never
like call this an icon like yeah in my
mind like I'm like on the bottom I'm
like a little pawn on the whole chess
board of like Christian stuff happening
and I'm just a little pawn that makes
like my cool weird images so yeah I
think some people get a kick out of that
so think so a lot of Oakland diagrams
overlapping yeah and I often talk about
in my in my work I talk about the notion
of the narthex or the art of the nach
narthex and the idea of the bridge art
or the limit liminal art right and so
that's when I saw you work I kind of
right away felt like that's one of the
roles you seem to play and when you're
just you're discussing the type of
people that are interested in your work
it seems to make sense that it would be
those kinds of people you know because
because there is an aspect like I said
to see yourself like at the bottom using
imagery from popular culture and and and
kind of weird culture but then also
connecting it to more formal iconography
is something that would happen at the
bottom or on the edge or you know in a
place like the narthex which is a
transition between inside and outside so
you can have like you said people were
coming from psychedelic it's coming for
all this stuff and then all of a sudden
realizing that okay this Christian II
which I always thought was stupid all my
life because every all my teachers told
me it was stupid and all culture told me
it was stupid all of a sudden it's like
oh wait a minute no there's something
else going on here I don't know how to
grasp at it yet I don't know how to
attach myself to it yet but here's
something that I you know here are these
types of images that are and it's slowly
bringing me towards a fuller
understanding and something like that
totally yeah yeah there's this guy I
really like named benoit mandelbrot he
kind of like popularized you wouldn't
say discovered but he kind of made like
fractals a thing and like science and
mathematics and he has this quote which
is all established fields oh a great
debt to those scholars who are nomads by
choice because that's how he felt you
know he's not an artist but all his work
is visual he's not really a scientist
because it's more like the
radical math but he's not really a
mathematician because it's all about the
natural world kind of so I've always
really identified with that archetype
where it's like you know I'm not a
theologian but I really like theology
I'm not a sociologist but I'm really
into analyzing culture and I think a lot
of people can identify with that
especially now when things are kind of
getting more in mesh than ever
mmm yeah that makes sense I think that
your work has that quality to it to a
kind of a kind of hybrid monster kind of
hybrid monster work but there's a word
there's a place for that I talked about
st. Christopher a lot and the the
imagery of the of the monster as being
important like the gargoyle all of this
stuff is also part of the Christian
tradition we just have to understand its
role like it's a kind of thing where I
always joke about that because I make
t-shirts and I make all this stuff
tonight and I and I say things like you
know yeah I make t-shirts and but if I
saw priests wearing my t-shirt in the
altar I would physically eject him from
the altar like things are just have
their place you know if they're in the
right place then they're fine it's the
same with your images like if like I
love the images you're making but if I
some if I saw someone painting in the
middle of that lady decapitating an
alien like in the apse of a church I'd
be like dude you need to be
excommunicated you know it's just about
it's all about plates totally definitely
so I have a question it's almost like a
technical question but so in your work
there's a there's a little thing that
appears a lot and it's like this square
with the triangle in it and I'm trying
to like figure out what what it's what
it's reference like there there's a
version of it on the hand of this holy
lady decapitating the alien you see it
there's an image of us oh yeah nice yeah
totally yeah the guy in the church it's
called the amateur theologian I like
never title my work but that one is a
title like yeah amateur theologian
that's a great image yeah I drew this
because honestly like sometimes I'm
working and purely like you know oh I
want to explore this idea but I actually
drew this because it's like really how I
feel and how I felt especially like at
that time where it's kind of like you're
you know you're just like some random
guy but like you really want
figure out these like huge theological
issues that are like way beyond your
comprehension or like you know still
your beyond your station in life let's
say see I drew this guy he's almost like
anguished I guess like like like
screaming out kind of just like just
because what I just said he like knows
he's like just this one random guy but
he wants like figure it out so yeah
that's really literally how I feel all
the time uh yeah that it's supposed to
be like a little Jam like a little like
diamond or like a little jewel mm-hmm
that little square thing he's holding I
basically used that for a few reasons I
often have it on well well I kind of
picked it up I guess you could say I did
this image of Saint Augustine that's
probably my other most popular images
and I took it from this Renaissance
painting of him being coronated him
being like crowned and they're crowning
him with these white gloves and on the
white gloves is a big gem on the back of
the glove and I just drew it without
really thinking much about it and
someone told me there were these special
gloves yeah I think if you search for
like coronation of st. Augustine it's on
the Wikipedia page I'm pretty sure -
someone told me there were these gloves
they would wear and the jewel represents
like one of the wounds of Christ on his
hand and there would be these like red
gems to represent like those wounds
basically so yeah that's why I see I see
that yeah yeah so I guess you could say
like I don't really expect other people
to like pick up on it necessarily but I
often use it in that way where it's like
this red gem red often correlates with
like passion and like the passion and
like suffering in some way to mean so I
kind of thought of it that way it's like
this like redemptive aspect of like
suffering in my mind again I wouldn't
expect anyone to like pick up on that
but also the gem is kind of an
interesting symbol because gems are made
deep down in like the hidden parts of
the earth where there's like a ton of
pressure and you know all this time and
these huge like almost cosmological like
geological forces but they produce these
like beautiful wonders that then we have
to dig down deep in the earth to get so
obviously that's some like level of
symbolism there where like you know you
have to dig down to like find these
things that are like hidden in the earth
but ultimately you know are really
beautiful because they
from this like dark weird inaccessible
place yeah so yeah it's kinda like what
I think about the gem symbolism yeah the
gem symbolism is important because it
especially for Christians it's important
because it it's exactly what you said
it's it's related also to fish symbolism
which might sound surprising at first
yeah it's the idea of shiny things in
the darkness right and so that that in
the darkness are hiding that life is
hiding in the darkness and that Christ
one of the roles that Christ has is to
go down and to gather the fish gather
what is alive in the dark places so save
us from death go down into death and
take the souls out of death as part of
it but it's also this idea that the
seeds are hidden in the world right the
seeds of meaning the seeds of let's say
the hidden presence of God is there in
the world if you can dig in and find the
hidden gems right the parable of the
pearl in the field that you know the man
who sells his field who buys this field
to have the pearl or all these images of
like little things like small things the
seeds and and fish and everything so
yeah so the Jam is perfect in that sense
because you like you said you you
actually go down into darkness into
these dark caves and then you find these
glowing things it's almost as if they
have they brought light down into
darkness right they brought they they're
they're shiny and and so then they're so
then that ends up being the last the
last image of the world - is the city
which is covered in gems uhm yeah nice
that's true actually yeah yeah yeah it
also makes me think about you know like
society's relationship to those things
because the gym is also it's almost like
money like it inherently has like a
financial value but it's deeper
symbolism has like nothing to do with
that like commodification so I'll
sometimes think of it in that way it's
like something that society has taken
and been like oh hey you know this is
worth a lot of money right but it's like
actual value has like nothing to do with
that yeah yeah no you're told that
you're totally right and there's also
there's also an interesting tradition
about the idea this is more of a Jewish
tradition but it's interesting to think
about that the first tablets that Moses
made you know when Moses when Moses
received the tablets from God
the law that the first tablets the ones
he broke were made out of like a gem
because it just says they're stone
tablets we always imagine the stone
tablets as being like granite or
something but but the idea that the
first tablets would have been gems and
then the second tablets would have been
more coarser like coarser material is
related to this idea of something coming
down like that has to be brought down
lower in order to be seen but also the
idea of raising something from the earth
up so that it becomes full of light like
this gems that come up also gonna be
facet gems and so we we in order to make
them even more resplendent we have to
make them geometric right we have to
make them into like geometric shapes so
all of that totally is totally I think
it's very the symbolism jambs is really
something that I probably should make a
video on at some point because it is
very fascinating so where are you seeing
like where do you see yourself going
because that you talked about before we
started recording you talked about how
you're almost you're almost becoming
overwhelmed right now with commissions
and so where do you see yourself going
in terms of choosing your projects going
you know what direction would you like
to go with your art well yeah it's kind
of the main thing on my mind right now
well my setup is I used to live in I
used to live in a really big city and
then for a variety of reasons I just
kind of packed it all up and moved out
to kind of the middle of nowhere style
and yeah I'm really just trying to do my
art and have it work both as an outlet
for everything we've talked about but
also I may hate singing this way but
it's reality of like the world like kind
of like a business I guess you could say
I don't like have a family and stuff
like eventually so yeah it's been really
interesting man because the last year I
basically just been learning how to run
my little studio and I do have like a
little studio it's a little room that
I'm in right now and just figuring out
how to run it and everything how I want
to balance projects I'm really lucky
actually because there's not really a
conflict between what I see as projects
that would make the studio functional in
terms of like me being able to afford to
eat and then also things that I do want
to be doing I'm really lucky
both of those things have synced up
perfectly I don't really know what I
would do otherwise if I had to like fake
you know stuff that was gonna be like
commercially like viable but I'm lucky
that I doubt so yeah basically figuring
out how to run things man I really want
to start stepping up the caliber of what
I'm outputting I'm kind of at this point
where I always think of things in terms
of like weaponry analogies like I have
these like little armies out and all the
armies are doing pretty well so now I'm
back in the lab working on like you know
beaker more powerful weaponry for them
comics is something I've been exploring
that I feel like I have a lot of like
potential on I made a really long comic
about like sex and pornography and my
own like experiences with it recently
some more like weird tale comics also
the same style is what you've got going
now yeah it's actually on my website
under comics if you go to my website so
in cyclops calm by the way that's the
plug under comics it should be there
actually is it there I can send you the
PDF right now I don't it might not be
there yet actually but I'll send it to
you right now yeah I'd be interested
just because that's the comics is
something that I've been I've been kind
of diving into oh yeah I saw that you
were working on working on the comments
now I mean I'm not the one I'm not the
artist it's gonna need someone else but
I when I wrote it with my brother and so
yeah I'm excited to see I think the
potential of comics is really great for
someone's interested in symbolism you
know and it's been taken by the dark
side I would say you know you've got
people like like Alan Moore who's just
such an amazing has such an amazing
grasp on symbolic laying out of symbolic
structures within a page and so it's
like I just see him as my nemesis or
something like I need me you know that's
what you're shooting for and I suppose
I'm gonna shoot high cuz he's really
good he's really good at doing that
totally yeah so I send it to you right
now as a PDF yeah the comic thing is
something I really like a lot because I
enjoy the informational aspect of being
an illustrator that's the other thing
also I really use the term illustrator
intentionally because I'm not really a
fine artist like my work
you meant to like just Hank like not
that anyone would want this but like
hang in the museum or something like
that
I really do make like illustrations
where I tend to be like casually enjoyed
in this like other kind of like liminal
space
so yeah the comics thing is really cool
for me because I like writing but I'm
not a writer I would never really sit
down and just write a story but when
it's paired with the images then I
really do feel like it's something that
I I mean I think I'm good at it
obviously I do it
but yeah there's a lot of power there so
I made this comic it's just called sex
it's about like my kind of history with
like sex and pornography and stuff so I
thought a lot of like young men could
like relate to it yeah so totally
different than my other stuff but also
oddly like completely related to it and
yeah one of my plans is I kind of do
want to do like a longer like graphic
novel like that where I basically just
go through these like particular things
that like I personally like had to deal
with that I feel like a lot of like
other people have also wrestled with it
also really fits in with like the
Christian theology thing because
ultimately it's kind of how I ended up
there so that's something that I'm
working on it's kind of like a long-term
project where basically go through and
talk about like sex and drugs and cult
and all this stuff and then have it all
build up to like me kind of you know
figuring it out a little bit more I
think that's a great idea for a story
just because it's so relevant to what's
happening now and and you know the this
moment let's say where you have the kind
of new atheist type atheism it's kind of
breaking down and because that has that
has positive aspect but also has
negative aspects which people are
looking for kind of spiritual sustenance
but then they're looking all around and
you know not always finding the best
let's say so it's it that could be a
really good story to tell totally yeah
it's funny too because honestly like
it's a lot of stuff that I really never
thought I would talk about like you know
I'm on Twitter I'm you know it's a toen
broadcast by the way other plug yeah
yeah it's not I never imagined myself to
be this guy who's like hey by the way
like I used to drink a lot like here's
what that was like I'm like hey by the
way like I did ayahuasca like because I
feel like I'm the psychedelic stuff is
something I really never thought I'd end
up talking about a lot because I thought
everyone's been at a party or someone's
like hey you know I did ayahuasca and it
was crazy man I'm like I never want to
be that guy but then I go on like my
sisters like Normie Facebook and like
vice news is like hey do ayahuasca
Lindsay Lohan did ayahuasca like go on
the view they're gonna talk about
ayahuasca and I'm like okay kind of
house I like push back against this a
tiny bit yeah no I agree because people
in my own circle people that I admire
you know have been have been let's say
seen to it seems like they seem to be
pushing psychedelics as some kind of a
solution and you know I've never done
psychedelics alright it's not like I can
I can speak out of experience but I I do
feel like there's a there's an aspect of
the message that's missing and we need
to be careful as people kind of see this
as some solution to their problems that
they think that they're going to find it
there you know you there is no chemical
solution to your problems in you know in
terms of spirituality it's not that's
not possible it's not how that's not any
of this stuff works yeah I also feel
like you know I would normally feel
frankly like arrogant hey everyone like
listen to me about this thing but for me
it's more like there's really no and
this also fits in with like the you know
Christian worldview tying in with like
how culture is going and stuff I feel
like there's just no push back against
it at all I think that most people
probably 99% of people have probably
never heard anyone make the statement of
like yeah I used to do cycle at
psychedelics a ton and here's why I
think that is not a viable spiritual
path I think that in everyone's mind is
kind of just this reefer madness thing
where it's like whoa don't take acid
like you'll turn into a glass of orange
juice or something but uh I think the
intelligent case being made against that
stuff is almost at zero that goes a lot
of other things that I'm not really
about anymore but yeah it's one of the
only reasons why I kind of like started
talking about it more is that I was like
wow no one is either no one's equipped
to push back against it or no one's
doing it or I just haven't found them
yet but uh well I think that that's
maybe one of the issues one of the
issues is that let's say like I in my
normy state in the sense that I like
I've never done psychedelic so I don't
have the tools to push against it either
and I just kind of see it weird like I
I've noticed that a lot of the things
that well one of the things that I have
noticed is that despite the fact that
people tell me
how much insight psychedelics bring
brings them when I talk to people who've
done a lot of psychedelics I don't
necessarily feel like they have more
insight and so I mean it not to be
arrogant but I just I just don't see
your insight I see tell me you have
insight but I don't see you able to
communicate that insight somehow to the
world around you so so because of that
it's like I'm like I don't know man I I
don't want to be I don't like I said I
want to be the idiot and just say
drugged bad drug bad don't do drugs but
at the same time I was like I don't I
haven't seen I haven't seen let's say
that it that it necessarily gives
something good you know it seemed like a
chemical tool like any other chemical
tool totally yeah yeah well it's funny
actually gonna fix with like to hold the
whole fool thing that maybe we'll talk
about later but I think that in a lot of
cases it's almost and this goes with
like frankly everything that I'm kind of
against and like society honestly it's a
very like Emperor New Clothes style
situation where the lie is kind of like
so thick and everyone kind of takes it
for granted that it really takes someone
who is kind of willing to like maybe
even look like an idiot to be like hey
actually like everyone's saying the down
is up but have you ever thought about
the up is up and then people are like
well actually I never I never like
thought about that actually and I feel
like that about second honestly dude
like the whole time that I was in that
world with a ton of different people
doing in a ton of different contexts all
over like whatever I feel like there was
almost never anyone who expressed any
skepticism whatsoever and the first time
that I had someone be like hey have you
ever thought about like maybe this isn't
like a hundred percent great I was like
wow it's almost why I actually actually
I haven't ever thought about that Wow
so yeah it's a very I love damper New
Clothes story especially now because
that's like really how it is like you
need a little kid to be like what if do
it what if smoking weed literally all
the time is bad and you're like oh yeah
what if that is bad like so yeah do some
people are sitting and they're like what
are you talking about but yeah people in
that world know I'm talking about it I
feel obliged to reach out to people that
are kind of like in the same tide pool
that I used to be in let's say so some
people probably are like what are you
talking about but some people are like
that's yeah
all right so now what I want to talk
about because you've been talking for a
while but I do want to talk about the
image that we kind of made together so I
I've had this this theme in my mind
where I've been talking about the notion
of the fool my brother as well talks
about this quite a bit in his book the
language of creation the idea that the
the fool is always turning and he's
always turning things but the strange
thing happens when things are already
upside down when the world is already
upside down is that the fool will
continue turning and then we'll end up
reinstating the though that's a
reinstating authority or reinstating the
king and so I had this idea that of a
Joker card which could have a joker on
one side and a king on the other and
they could it looks like the Joker was
turning the king and I actually tried to
draw it myself and then I was like now
this is not good like I just it's just
not the type of image of that I'm really
that I'm really it comes close to the
art I'm doing it so you just didn't
never look right and then when I saw
your art I thought okay this guy this
guy he's the one who can put it together
and so you did and I love it I just
think it's so awesome so maybe you can
tell me a bit about the process you went
through to kind of to kind of bring this
image together
nice nice cool well I'm glad you I'm
glad you feel that way I'm glad I was
able to step in in our role yeah I'm
super cool working with you and doing it
um
process wise well yeah you told me about
that idea and it's something that I
resonated with really strongly I mean
you take on Commission so I think you
probably know there's a spectrum of
someone being like hey can you draw this
and you're like yeah I probably could
and then sometimes people are like I can
you draw this and you're like oh yeah
yeah I could definitely draw that so
yeah something I resonated with really
strongly um I really really really the
fool archetype is like a big part of
like what I'm about for sure so I guess
we can go into that more but yeah I
really resonated with it and in terms of
the vision like the purely visual like
purely putting it together like in a
visual sense yeah I felt like it was
perfect for my style because like you
were saying before it's almost like
everything in my art is kind of like
flat but in this weird way where it's
like flat but also kind of like has
depth I think I got that from
the medieval art where you know it's
like the picture plane that you're
looking at isn't really a window into a
three-dimensional space it's almost
utilizing like the flat make sure of the
surface you're looking at to convey
information to the viewer so yeah we
talked about it a little bit since some
sketches back and forth I think the most
interesting thing for me was conveying
the idea behind it of like the fool
really flipping the King over and we got
this like spin with the cards on the
back but yeah one of the things I liked
about it and that we hadn't talked about
because I just said you know I'd like
the fool to be like kind of grabbing the
King and flipping him over one of the
things I like and I don't even know if
you did it on purpose so you can tell me
if you did but I like the fact that he's
that he's not taking the king by the
hand right he's grabbing him by the arm
and it almost looks like the king is
resisting it's AMA look if the king is
resisting he doesn't actually want this
to happen but if the fools like gasps
sorry buddy this is happening like
orders coming back even if the King
doesn't want it to happen yeah no
totally yeah yeah that was definitely
intentional yeah when I'm working with I
guess all my work is kind of like this
when I'm working with more of like a
simplified like I keep using this word
but informational way of like conveying
visuals people's body language even like
really subtle aspects of it it's
something that I really really think
about a lot probably an extent that
people would probably find like kind of
weird so yeah I definitely made an
intentional because I wanted to make it
clear that he was like the leader
pulling him I had this art teacher once
and she she did this exercise where she
had people line up and she went to hand
someone a pencil and before she gave him
the pencil she had them freeze she went
to hand someone a you know a ball and
had them freeze handsome and somebody
else had them freeze and you could see
that their hands even just the way they
were the frozen people the way they were
positioned you could tell what object
they were about to receive from how
their hands were and that really made me
realize that yeah like everything about
someone's body language even how their
fingers are anything conveys like their
state and you know what they're doing
and what they're feeling so yeah I made
it I made an intentional for sure and
it's also even with the thumb out it's
kind of like he's like pulling
yeah as well like casually kind of like
authoritative Lee like whoa here we go
like flipping over so yeah that was
definitely intentional yeah that's
awesome
so tell me a bit about you The Fool why
you feel the fool is something that you
connect with yeah
probably for a lot of reasons on a
purely like I guess not purely surface
level but in the most like basic way I
feel like you know tying back to like
the Emperor's New Clothes thing I feel
like we're dealing with like a world
whether you're like into politics or
just culture or even just theology and
religion or just living your life and
hanging out we're kind of dealing with a
world where things are so inverted and
people get like the wrong idea about
what you're saying and there's all these
kind of like informational archetypes
launch like I'm sure anyone watching
this probably has been in a conversation
where you know you say something and
then what the other person here is it's
like a stereotype of what you're saying
and then they can't actually hear the
words that you're trying to get out and
I feel like the fool is like a really
powerful way of like bypassing that it's
almost like the fool is able to cut
through all the rules of like how
language and information is meant to be
structured in society and because of
that he can get at these deeper truths
without attracting these like you know
crosshairs onto him come that's one of
the one of the aspects of a gesture you
know the gesture could even like
critique the King because he's like
quote-unquote like just joking and
that's something I've always resonated
with really strongly the whole time I've
been you know doing anything like this
even when I was just posting on Twitter
and stuff you know I'd get people
damning me all the time like hey this is
really cool but like are you joking or
not like I can't tell and I feel like
that lets me honestly I kind of like get
away with a lot of stuff because you
know if you feel strongly about anything
if you just come out and you're like oh
I feel you know it doesn't only matter
what it is let's say it's gun control it
doesn't matter if you just make a post
that's like hey we should all be allowed
to own these guns everyone's kind of
like okay like whatever but if you make
it something funny or make it like a
joke or maybe like subtly you know then
it gets a lot more traction and people
are more interested in it and especially
with something more controversial than
that whatever it would be you can reach
more people if it's kind of like hey I'm
just joking but like am I just joking
like you can't really tell there's
there's this alchemy book I never
actually I just thought in a bookstore
once but it was called a serious joke
and I really just loved that title cuz
it's like yeah it's a joke but what the
fools saying can also be like serious
there's not actually that I kata me
there that people imagine yeah well
that's what the people who are using
memes right now those that are using
memes almost in a weaponized manner
that's what they understand you know all
the four chan 8chan types they
understand how the use of irony's and
double irony's and all of this is a way
to it's like an in and it's a way to
kind of change the world without people
understanding exactly what's going on
yeah exactly exactly there's also kind
of the The Fool also dovetails with like
certain elements of like mysticism I
guess you could say maybe you know like
there's the fools for Christ and like
Eastern Christianity and then in Western
Christianity there's also the kind of
like the mystical fool Arco st. Francis
is really that I mean he's usually he's
usually not people don't seem to see it
that way but Fran st. Francis does all
the things that the fool that the fool
does like he he undresses himself in
public he does all kinds of crazy stuff
you know so he's definitely a fool -
fool type as well totally yeah I also
feel like when we live in this world
that is such like a um I don't even know
what to call it almost like a cult of
like this particular type of like
intellectualism where it's like you have
these like intellectual authorities
they're kind of like are telling you
what to think I guess would be the most
basic way to put it
The Fool has like a really interesting
role to play in all that I guess you
could say ya know the fool is is
undermining that's the that's the rule
of the fool and he's and so it's
sometimes it's dangerous right sometimes
it can be it if it goes too far in one
direction sometimes it can be a
destabilizing force um in small doses
it's actually healthy because like you
said it prevents the king from puffing
himself up or thinking that he's
self-sufficient right some point the
authority thinks that they've got it
covered when the fool is there to say
yeah you know what this this thing that
you're hiding here you know this secret
that you got is not it's showing that
there's there's a piece there's some
stones lacking in
your Tower of Babel you know and so that
fool is useful for that as well um but
I'm really for now at least I'm really
interested rather in how because the the
revolutionary types the those that were
there to destabilize society to a
certain extent because they become so
powerful and they've actually taken over
and a lot of the institutions then the
fool in that role now the sudden is
looks very strange because the fool is
actually trying to take power away from
those that were that we're trying to be
revolutionary and so it's just
interesting because it really goes for
this strange double irony where it's
like what happens when those what
happens when contemporary art you know
the thing in terms of just art into why
art which is there supposedly to be
transgressive is now in in the
guggenheim all over the world and there
are these multi-million dollar buildings
and are being propped up by the
institutions like what is going on how
is it possible that something which is
supposed to be to be questioning
authority is now taken up by the highest
authority well that's when the fool of a
sudden you know becomes a very strange
figure because the fool is bringing back
iconography like in your case you're
like bringing back iconography using
almost like a subversive language which
is still there but it's it's pointing
towards something else and so and that's
one of the reason why I liked it were
two because I can see that that double
flip that I talked about or this double
inversion where you know someone who is
using imagery that is that looks
subversive at first glance like when I
look at your work at first glance I it
looks like graffiti or looks like you
know kind of esoteric weird esoteric
stuff but as soon as you do a double
glance you see oh no and there's
something else going on it's actually
pointing towards something else so yeah
that's something else I kind of picked
up that I guess really actually does fit
with the fool archetype someone I really
liked I mean I still like him he's still
cool is Bill Watterson the guy that did
Calvin and Hobbes mm-hmm and he actually
talked about kind of what you were just
getting out a little bit where because
it's like quote-unquote like just a
newspaper comic and people aren't
expecting something deep from it when he
did do a comic about like you know maybe
like a bird dying or something like that
he could kind of just like
sneak in like a big punch and get at
these like way deeper things themes
because oh it's like just a comic it's
just this like little thing it's kinda
like the fool like oh I'm just playing
around and then boom you like sneak in
something that otherwise people would
have like a ton of filters up for ya and
it acts as almost like a Zen : right it
actually goes really deep and will like
shock it can shock your worldview in a
way that you you weren't prepared for
right but you weren't guarding for let
say and so yeah it can have a very deep
effect I totally agree yeah that was the
other thing that I really responded to
about your initial kind of like our
discussion about it was like the idea of
you know what happens when things are
already inverted and you have this
figure that inverts things it's actually
like a really interesting like paradox I
guess that's kind of what I was getting
at with like the the cult of like
intellectualism I guess you could say
because we're kind of this in this
position where like you know things are
so much about like having the right view
and trusting like the right authorities
and stuff that I feel like the fool
plays into that and an interesting way
too because it's almost like we're in
this position where like the smartest
questions you can ask will sound to most
people like the dumbest questions you
could ask and I feel like that's kind of
a big part of like how I got led down
this road and everything you know like
we're all like so confident and all this
like you know scientific explanations
for the universe but then you're like
yeah but like where we're the first like
living thing come from you know it
sounds like kind of a dumb question but
it's not really or like yeah why are
there like all these things around or
you know I always think of Isaac Newton
for example you know kind of a bridge
between like esoterica and science like
this the classic like tale of him like
sitting under a tree and then being like
you know wait why do apples like fall
down like what's up with that I thought
there's some fool energy there just
asking like the dumbest question
possible and then it leads you to you
know changing the world the whole world
yeah totally
all right man I think I think I think
we've had a great conversation I tend to
have these go for now we've been going
even more so so I'm really looking
forward to seeing how people are going
to react to this image we did together
so people write down your your your
comments your ideas in the in the
comments section we can see you know
what you think and
yeah who knows he could lead to maybe
some more collaborations that could be
fun
totally man Yahoo should stay on each
other's radar I'm definitely down we
could talk more whatever I think we have
an interesting you know with certain
overlap certain things are different so
yeah I really enjoy talking you man I'm
super interesting yeah thanks for coming
out yeah thanks for having me here hope
you enjoyed my discussion with Owen
Cyclops make sure to check out the image
we made together in my TSP account and
see if it's something you would be
interested in getting this is really a
collaboration we did together and so for
each t-shirt or merch item that is sold
a part of the profits that goes directly
to Owen as well so everybody thanks for
your attention and I will see you soon